midterm elections are now less than
seven weeks away and the latest CBS News
Battleground tracker poll focuses on two
very close races in the state of Georgia
Democratic senator Rafael Warnock leads
his Republican Challenger that's virtual
Walker 51 to 49 percent in our poll
that's considered very tight there while
Republican Governor Brian Kemp leads
Democrat Stacey Abrams 52 to 46 percent
this is a rematch of their 2018 campaign
Nicole killing is tracking the races
that voters expect will remain very
close right through election day
hello Georgian after flipping for
President Biden and helping to clinch
the majority in the U.S Senate Georgia
is once again on midterm Minds why do
you think this race is so close
sir I'll let the pundits
you know do that Democratic incumbent
Senator Rafael Warnock gets higher marks
than President Biden from Peach State
voters according to CBS News
Battleground tracker they say they like
how Warnock handles himself compared to
GOP Challenger Herschel Walker giving
him more favorable ratings as someone
who has good character is a role model
and more experienced there is such a
huge difference between the two
candidates
um Senator wanak has already proved
himself
what is it about Herschel that you like
he's not one Oak the race has turned
increasingly personal with both
candidates only recently agreeing to
debate we have debate around this place
all the time
and if you're not ready for a debate
you're not ready I'm this country boy
you know I'm not that smart and he's
that preacher he's a smart man wear
these nice suits so he's going to show
up and embarrass me at the debate while
Walker's campaign says he was just using
sarcasm the Trump back former Heisman
Trophy winner has been plagued by a
series of gaps and misleading statements
about his past it's Herschel Walker
versus the truth Raphael Warnock we see
him on TV but what is he really hiding
more than 138 million dollars has been
spent on ads in the senate race making
it one of the most expensive in the
country along with the governor's race
where the economy remains front and
center everything's going up so the
house going up the interest going up I
think the state has advanced
educationally financially more than half
of registered voters think it's going
well in Georgia compared to the rest of
the country something GOP incumbent
Brian main Camp hopes to capitalize on
as he faces a rematch against Democrat
Stacy a rumps I'm going to run on my
record we've got a great economy here in
the state of Georgia how do you kind of
cut through that narrative we know that
the current governor is spending
Democratic delivery dollars in order to
tackle these challenges but I want us to
invest those dollars in the very people
who need them
Abrams narrowly lost camp in 2018 and
she is largely credited with helping
Democrats flip the state not only last
year but in 2020 and she told me she's
confident that Playbook will work again
she is making a strong push for early
voting which kicks off in just a couple
of weeks Nate
Nicole thank you